the 2021 golden globes have wrapped but
that doesn't mean we can't relive the
biggest
can't miss moments from the show what
the heck is this gonna be
because usually we're you know working
the crowd and the crowd are at home
tina fey and amy poehler hosted the
first bi-coastal
mostly virtual ceremony on sunday night
you won't even notice tina and amy
called on their snl
family to help out with keenan thompson
maya rudolph and kristen wiig
bringing the laughs but of course with
any live award show
there's going to be flubs like when
another snl alum tracy morgan went to
announce seoul as
winner for best original score and the
golden globe goes to
sounds
tracy got roasted for the flub on social
media he soon tweeted
sorry soul i was thinking about the
pizza i was going to get for my guy
sal on the way home and when daniel
kaluuya won
best supporting actor for his acclaimed
role in judas and the black messiah
a technical difficulty almost robbed him
of his big speech
me die he didn't even moment he did me
die you're doing me die am i on is this
on
is this on all right cool
can you hear me now all right cool we've
got this people
it's a pandemic bro it got into the
wi-fi
they got into the wi-fi my god
kaluya's black panther co-star the late
chadwick boseman
won the golden globe for his performance
in mahraini's black bottom
i like you i got talent the late actor's
wife taylor
simone ledward tearfully accepted his
posthumous win
for best actor in a motion picture drama
and i don't have his words
but we have to take all the moments to
celebrate those we love
and hone
you keep them coming the virtual home
setting led to personal
and often adorable family moments and
since fellow nominees were present
during speeches it's always nice to get
some assistance in wrapping up
and don's right i gotta wrap this puppy
up you know never been never been my
forte
hey that's just kansas city love if
anybody's gonna tell me to wrap it up
he knew i'd listen to him that's all
that is you know a lot of people don't
know that he's an excellent stage
manager as well as an
you know american acting icon like
that's
that's the guy's got chops you know but
one speech we never wanted to end
was jane fondas who spoke passionately
as she accepted the cecil b demille
award
the hollywood foreign press association
was repeatedly called out during the
telecast for recent criticisms
mostly due to not having a single black
member in their 87
person organization it is great to be
black at the golden globes back
back at the golden globes with hfpa
leaders taking the stage and
vowing to do better going forward